make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
the aftermath of the last video that we
did which was the king in black and it
had null and we ended up finding out
that the silver surfer was kind of this
voice that was coming in at the end of
it i was cruising through the comments
and a lot of you guys were kind of like
okay like what's up with the silver
surfer
so what i figured we'd do here is go
back and cover a story that's actually
really important to understand
the silver surfer as he exists now is
part of the king and black event and
that's a story called
silver surfer black uh this basically is
the first time the silver surfer
encounters null so this takes place
quite some time before the king and
black event but i wanted to cover this
here so you guys
basically have a better understanding of
what's going on with norn rad's
characters so what this initially does
is it kind of picks up sort of a
refresher for the silver surfer and
that's where these comics usually go
right for a character like the silver
surfer whom you don't really see all
that often with somebody like iron man
captain america
you don't really get a refresher when it
comes to this right it's largely just
kind of relying on your knowledge of
previous issues because you see them all
the time but with somebody like silver
surfer it's kind of like
you don't really see them all that often
right and so uh it kind of gives us a
little bit of a run down in the sense
that he's the herald of galactus that he
kind of goes along and does his own
thing
but it also ties into like the old jack
kirby and stan lee and even the post uh
fantastic four first appearance stories
that focus heavily on the nature of the
silver server which is to say the kind
of
morality that comes with him knowing
that he's basically a guy who leads
galactus to worlds
uh that in in days gone by would
normally have been devoid of life but
that in this day and age he largely just
takes him to whatever planet he needs
and in this instance with these
different worlds that have been consumed
by galactus there was one world in
particular that was interesting in the
sense that when the silver surfer showed
up as kind of a harbinger
and basically said like your world's
gonna die you know so get out while you
can
uh that the people on that world
actually came together and sing songs as
praise to
to silver surfer they almost kind of saw
him as a god and this is kind of
of morality that he consistently
struggled with right this idea that he's
basically
ending the lives of of entire
civilizations on various worlds
because galactus needs to consume right
it's the role he plays in the universe
and so it's one of these things where it
kind of gives us this little bit of a
moral
imperative for his character which will
become important later on because of
course we pick up in the aftermath of
the initial guardians of the galaxy
story and
a lot of that kind of came out of
infinity wars which was a terrible story
in effect in the aftermath of this like
thanos was dead um
that in the black order or whatever you
want to call it a thanos kind of showing
up and basically opening like this
dimensional rift that started sucking in
all these various characters and you
guys can find that video from the
guardians of the galaxy down in the
description
uh the silver surfer was was effectively
stuck in this sucked into this
dimensional rift and it's one of the
ways that marvel plays things kind of
fast and loose when it comes to that
sort of thing happening
by and large as far as i understand it
right now when it comes to like black
holes here in the real world we don't
really know what happens right all we
know is that matter just kind of gets
broken down on the atomic level
uh and then it ends up being trapped
inside of a black hole right there's
theories that black holes are portals to
other dimensions
there's theories that black holes
basically open up into white holes in
and on other sides of the universe
they're just something akin to like a
wormhole a teleportation device
in effect it allows you to sort of bend
the barriers of space and time to leave
one or to enter from one part of the
universe and arrive in a different part
of the universe that we don't really
know exactly what goes on there right
it's just at this point theoretical
science and so the results of this
is that marvel kind of plays it fast and
loose sometimes black holes really are
dimensional portals sometimes black
holes are just
gravity wells right like if you go and
you read annihilation there's a point
where rocket raccoon tells thanos
that if he keeps on freaking out they're
gonna drop him into a gravity well and
he'll just be in there forever
right because a black hole is not enough
to kill thanos but it is enough to keep
him trapped and he'll just be stuck
in infinite darkness forever and ever
and ever and ever in essence
infinite life right he'll never be able
to die uh so we kind of see marvel
playing it in different ways depending
on the situation in this scenario
marvel treats these kind of dimensional
riffs or artificial black holes or what
have you
as basically dimensional barriers right
that where uh the silver surfer is able
to use this power to kind of get a lot
of people out there
and to essentially save them at least to
some degree trying to race out at the
same time
he's ultimately ultimately trapped and
the result of that is he wakes up
in this place where there really is no
light whatsoever now
based on hindsight on what we know about
null and things like that he's basically
woking
woken up in the realm of no but there's
a little more going on with regards to
this place he's waking up in
than is initially given to us we'll find
more about that as time goes on
but what he starts to realize is that in
this place he's in that of course there
is eternal darkness but there are these
moments or at least you know a huge
amount of darkness but there are these
moments when like a light will flicker
into existence
and then it'll disappear it'll come into
existence and then it'll vanish right
stars are literally blinking in and out
just consistently now we know a lot of
that has to do with the fact that null
prizes just kind of oblivion right the
idea of darkness
death things like that there is no light
in this realm that he lives in and so
that's why we're kind of able to look at
this in hindsight and know that it is in
effect the the place that null calls
home
but silver surfer finds this place
hugely unfamiliar right and so he does
the only thing he really can do which is
to
dawn his surfboard and then to take off
right and ultimately come across this
place that he sees as being some sort of
planet
uh that has at least a small flickering
of light on it and then basically arrive
there and find out what's going on the
problem is that as soon as he gets there
he's immediately met with this
colossal doorway and these sentinels
that basically stand guard
right these these three individual
beings there who almost act as
is you know guards of this this place
and so what's kind of crazy a silver
surfer approaches it the way that he
normally approaches things and it's kind
of interesting to look at him because
when you see him over the years
especially in more recent years he's a
lot more he has a lot more personality
than he used to and he's very much an
adventurer but when you look at it like
in this situation it's a lot of
curiosity
that in in the fact that he's seemingly
in a very very weak state given the
amount of energy he had to expend in
order to try to get out of this
out of this gravity well uh the fact
that this it was an exceedingly
difficult thing for him and ultimately
he ended up just
tiring out and acquiescing and allowing
himself to be sucked in
then at this point he does the only
thing he can do which is coming to them
for help
the problem is that when he talks to
them he's like i mean you no harm you
know do you have a master
they kind of start speaking to him but
the language and this is something kind
of interesting the language is something
he sort of picks up on and it's
interesting because we haven't really
seen a language like that before and so
it really just kind of goes to the
nature of silver server having traveled
so consistently but there's also a bit
of a clue there and we'll find out what
that clue is here in the future videos
that we do
but he registers this in saying that
like you know you're like
what they effectively said is our master
is god and so it's kind of like okay
this is kind of wonkers you know kind of
kind of kind of wonky here kind of
bonkers
and so they immediately attack the
silver surfer and right off the bat it's
like okay
and that's one of the things where
silver surfer was always written in an
interesting way where
on one hand if you're a villain or some
kind of being out there and you come
across him for the first time
he almost appears a little naive and
it's very easy for
people who are unfamiliar with the
surfer to perceive his curiosity as
naivety right to believe that he just
doesn't really know what he's getting
into but he's nobody's fool right and
when it comes down to it the silver
surfer has it where it counts that's why
like the old school stories right the
old school silver surfer stories written
like the 70s and the 80s
were really amazing if you sat down and
actually looked at them for what they
were
because he had a huge amount of power
and it was kind of this thing where
unless he was approaching somebody like
thanos
and he was kind of like okay i have to
be on my guard he would show up to you
and just kind of be like huh like
you're interesting but if you chose to
pick a fight you would regret it
fast it was it was nuts they were nut
stories i i love those old silver
silver server stories from back in the
day but he's immediately on guard and
just immediately calls for his board and
it's kind of like okay like at this
point it's bobbing and weaving the the
thing about this though is that while it
is a combination of silver surfer being
in a weakened state
these guys are also exceedingly powerful
but notice this the goal of the silver
surfer is not to destroy them
the goal of the silver surfer is to
incapacitate them and that's why you
don't see him just obliterating them or
attacking them or something like that
what what makes this even more you know
a little more difficult is we don't even
know if he could if he tried and not
even that silver surfer seems to know
whether or not he could actually destroy
them
because when he's fighting this battle
it's not just the midst of fighting them
it's the midst of fighting them and what
they're capable of right so like being
able to manipulate the ground
different things like that right these
guys are exceedingly powerful
but ultimately with this fight going on
silver surfer realizes they are fighting
to the death right their goal is to
destroy him
not to incapacitate him so it's like
okay enough is enough right this is your
last chance
yield or i'm going to destroy you and so
one of the cool things about the surfer
is that because he's been around for so
long and because he's faced so many
enemies from so many different places
it's very very easy for him to pick up
on the weaknesses of people as they
exist out there
and in this place where there seems to
be constant darkness where their goal is
to kind of suffocate him
in this realm of darkness then it's okay
right then
essentially their weakness seems to be
light and so in this fight that he's
engaging in as they begin to overwhelm
him as they begin to take him over he
does the only thing he really can do
which is to create this kind of
artificial sun
which just lets off this huge amount of
light and seemingly just
incapacitates him right just takes him
right out but it does come at a cost
and that's why his hand looks shriveled
and dark now again we'll learn more
about that as we go through these
different videos these different stories
but it's this cool moment where once
this light is dawned
in this place suddenly we realize it's
not some kind of a hellish landscape
right this is a lush and beautiful place
and that's when server realizes these
people
are probably not native to this land
they may be
but as far as you can tell that they're
individuals who seem to have been
conscripted into their role by whatever
force it is that happens to live here
and so you get this really really
amazing moment where this door opens up
right the store basically you know
this great big huge place opens up and
this hand just reaches out
and grabs him right and says like hello
little son like well
met and that's one of the crazy things
is surfer does this monologue right he
says like what dwells beyond
this gate has the power to enslave gods
to to
unmake the stars in the sky a long
forgotten voice
and the back of my mind screams as i'm
taken by this
black and i'm snatched in here and this
voice says be careful traveler
here there be dragons and that's when
you basically end up having null who
snatches silver surfer through this void
pulls him in into this doorway and
seemingly traps him inside his own
dimension and this is the first time
that we end up having the silver surfer
ever encountering null
in the history of marvel comics and what
follows after this
is absolute madness because it gets
ridiculously insane
especially when we get into the
involvement of galactus but with that
being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you